no why not what's up with round of
applause
I haven't done anything yet but why not
let's go okay good morning everybody so
today I'm going to be talking about
machine learning in healthcare why my
radiologist does not yet an algorithm so
just always helpful I think they start
with an outline so I'm gonna start with
the hype surrounding radiology and AI
the reality underlying that hypo through
two examples and then maybe we'll talk
about the limitations of current AI
algorithms in radiology and they're
ending off with the future of radiology
and a I hope ending on a more positive
note as hopefully you'll see so they
were secondary to the comic I think this
is a relatively app comic for the hype
surrounding machine learning and
artificial intelligence these days right
you just throw in a fade in there mix
things around eventually you get
something looks good so here I just want
to go over some of the headlines I've
been saying for the past couple of years
regarding artificial intelligence and
radiology so this is a piece by The New
Yorker this very antagonistic
relationship between artificial
intelligence and doctors a piece from
VentureBeat about this the unanimous AI
swarm technology that does 22% more
accurate pneumonia diagnosis mi t--'s AI
can identify breast cancer risk as
reliably as a radiologist from the BMJ
can artificial intelligence make doctors
obsolete from NPR radiologist see their
futures at risk from Fox about AI and
Alzheimer's that there's it's six years
better order predicts it's six years
earlier then doctors do even the New
England Journal of Medicine is getting
on this with a opinion piece that
machine learning will displace much of
the work of radiologists and anatomical
pathologists and then and from and Ruane
one of the leaders in the field of
artificial intelligence saying that they
have a algorithm for demo for diagnosing
pneumonia from chest x-rays better than
radiologists so now we're not even as
good as we're now better than
radiologists and finally fitting
finishing off with the quote from Geoff
Hinton this is about two year old quote
but I think it's very interesting he's
saying at the end that it's just
completely obvious that in five years
deep learning is going to do better than
radiologists and we just stopped
training them now well that's simple I
think that's pretty clear so yeah we're
good
so let's talk about the reality this is
actually true and I think this is also
cute so like Casey Dave you can tell I
think he has really great comics that
really kind of sum up the field in
general right that some things that seem
simple might not be nearly as simple so
let's take a look so this is the this is
the paper by enjoying this is the checks
net algorithm which he developed at
Stanford and radiologist level pneumonia
detection on chest x-rays with deep
learning so let's look at the claim the
claim is that chest check set exceeds
the average radiologists performance at
pneumonia detection so on the Left we
have the radiologist test on the right
we have the checks net they both are
looking at a same radiograph so this is
a chest x-ray we see the heart in the
middle and so the checks net is asked to
do either a pneumonia or not in demonio
detection so technically this is
actually a multi multi class 1 versus
rest task that was given but we can
think this is a binary classification
okay you're given a radiograph this does
have pneumonia or not meddling in it the
radiologists are also given a task not
nearly as simple they're given they're
told I hopefully everyone can read this
in the back but they're given 14
different diagnoses to work on and
there's actually a multi-label
classification task so an image can have
anywhere between 1 to 14 different
labels so right off the bat we seeing
that they're not really given the same
task the radiation radiology are given a
much more complicated task to do than
the algorithm additionally when
radiologists work their workflow
involves you start off with the not just
a single image we're looking at the
frontal view of the lateral view and
chest x-ray and different imaging
modalities will have different views
they also have a clinical indication
there's a reason why a patient was taken
was had an x-ray taken it's not just
because you know I mean it's a Tuesday
there's something wrong with this
patient or something hopefully getting
better with this patient that's
indicating an x-ray to being with and
that is essential for any reading of an
x-ray radiologist and finally finally
radiologists are almost always given
previous scans that tell them a fuller
picture of this Phillip picture of
what's happening with this patient what
was their scan yesterday what was the
day before that how have they changed
over time this is how radiologists read
x-rays
however for this task they weren't given
any of that they were given a single
film
about any other information and told
solvent so it's like if I asked everyone
here to run a race but I'm gonna
blindfold you and tie your shoelaces it
should I tie your shoelaces together we
probably wouldn't do that well and so
it's not really started surprising that
checks check that this checks an
algorithm which is trained specifically
on this one passed though is better than
radiologists who are doing a test they
don't normally do and then there's one
more thing I want to really address is
just three of these terms so
infiltration pneumonia and consolidation
so there's a problem of three three
terms is that they all come in the exact
same thing and so infiltration is
actually archaic term that is no longer
really Appel supposed to be used by
itself when diagnosing or when reading
films pneumonia is a diagnosis not a
finding and consolidation is an actual
radiological finding so the problem of
the problem is that if the radiologist
labeled it as a consolidation they might
be considered wrong because hey was a
pneumonia not a consolidation even
though they can mean the exact same
thing so for these three reasons I don't
think this claim is actually as powerful
as you'd like to make it seen it's
definitely very interesting algorithm
and it is great at a single specific
task of looking at chess x-rays from one
view and trying to identify a pneumonia
but I would not definitely not call it
better than radiologists it's better
than radiologists who are hobbled and
given a much harder task and so let's
look at one more of these papers so this
is deep radiology net radiologists level
pathology detection in CT head images so
the claim is a deep rheology net missed
less positive CT studies than
radiologists ie that had a lower false
negative rate so once again let's
compare the task of the radiologist and
this deep radiology net algorithm so
interestingly enough they did not
actually do a one-to-one comparison
their measure of radiologists
performance is actually based on a
literature review and so what they did
was they said okay from the literature
we can estimate that there's an average
error rate of about one point two
percent for radiologists and 68% of
those errors based on other papers
they're looking at our false negatives
so therefore our false negative rate for
radiologists is point zero eight three
percent which AUSA it didn't previous
load pretty low to me so let's look at
our D pretty LG net algorithm what they
did is they
on about 30,000 studies which comes out
to about five million images which as
I'll come to a little bit later is
actually a really nice data set most
people do not have million updated that
much data to work with well they did was
something very interesting what they
said is okay if we take the 8.5% of that
data set and what your algorithm is most
confident it only has the false negative
rate of point zero three seven percent
that seems low bit fishy to me
right radiologists don't get the option
of saying well I'm not really sure what
this graph looks like so I'm just not
going to count it but they all do that
they're saying only if we only take the
ones we're most sure about then we do
much better than the radiologists they
then said okay but I'm gonna say we take
about half the studies well then we do
pretty much just about the radiologists
and they don't actually report how well
the algorithm does when it has to do all
the studies I'm assuming it does much
worse than the radiologists so and once
again this is not a knock on there
algorithm I totally really get out for
them I'm just saying the data does not
back up their claim that they're better
than radiologists if they cherry pick
their cases sure they can do better than
the radiologists who does not have that
opportunity right but when they just
have to work with the exact same amount
of data that the radiologists have I
don't think they're even close to
radiology level radiologists level
performance so the question now is why
what's so hard about medical imaging or
what's different about medical imaging
than any other type of imaging right
because I don't know I've been told that
machine learning or a machine vision or
computer vision is pretty much a self
problem we could identify cats because
identified dogs were getting
self-driving cars why can't I do the
same thing for ad ology so I think
there's about four big issues with four
big limitations and differences between
radiology and a lot of other computer
vision fields and then one other aspects
realm and discuss at the end so I think
it's about complexity ground truth
quantity artifacts and then value add is
we'll come back to a little bit later so
first let's talk about the complexity so
we have our standard chest x-ray which
is honestly one of the simplest of
radiograph images to read and then we
have a koala bear very cute koala on the
right so the first thing to notice and I
think the first thing I would notice is
the fact that the Koala is in color the
chest x-ray is in art so already I've
lost one dimension of information
so forget about the complexity the test
was already harder to do next let's
actually look at these images this I do
not think is a fair comparison right on
the right I have a single object I'm
trying to identify is this a koala or
not okay after the most part you know
what you're seeing a chest x-ray the
question now is what are the diagnosis
inherit in a chest x-ray what are those
labels so do I have cardiomegaly do I
have a pneumothorax
do I have flail chest do I have an
infiltration do I have a consolidation
do I have pleurisy do I have I mean you
can go on and on there are literally
hundreds of different findings in a
chest x-ray compared to the one that I'm
pretty much saying in this koala so I
would call this an unfair comparison if
we want to think about what the natural
image comparison a chest x-ray might be
or just radiology in general something
much probably similar to this so this is
for if you can see in the back this is
just a group of the Serengeti of
wildebeests and now that I told you one
of these world the best well one of
these will wield a bit wildebeest has a
cold tell me which one based on this
image I think that's a much more fair
comparison right it's a much more
complicated image and I'm trying to find
the one or two pixels that tell me or
that that's different than the rest of
the image and that's different than
hundreds and thousands of other pictures
of similar wilderness let's talk about
ground truth as it applies to radiology
so there I think there are three big
issues in radiology the first is going
to be censored information so there's a
lot a problem with it there's a problem
with a lot of these studies and
algorithms and the big issue is
something called HIPAA which if you're
not aware of it's what regulates medical
imaging in the US and they actually
state or medical information in the US
and you know in case you ever wonder
what it stands for it's the health
information Portability and
Accountability Act if one thing's the P
stands for privacy
there's something about privacy in there
it's just about how we transmit
information but a big problem with that
is that you can't give away patient
information and so radiographs are fine
because there's no patient information
in there but a lot of other information
does have that so when there are a lot
of these algorithms are built on these
images they have no other information
but the image itself so they're missing
a lot of the information which would
tell them the ground truth ie let's say
they have a lab test to diagnose whether
it's pneumonia a pathological finding or
something else I really can tell you
what the image actually means they don't
have that information
and either even if they do the problem
is it's in terms of labeling because
when we talk about validating pictures
of koalas or the pictures of
self-driving cars pretty much anyone can
label that that's the whole point of
Mechanical Turk right Amazon can pay you
20 20 30 cents an image just to say okay
it's a koala it's a dog it's a cute dog
it's not such a cute dog right but
family you can't really do that with
radiologists because radiologists are
much more expensive for some reason I
don't know I offer them 20 cents an
image and they laughed at me I tried I
offered them some cookies no nothing so
what we tend to do instead is use
natural language processing to extract
information from the radiographs however
the problem with well not just radiology
reports but medicine in general is that
medicine and rails reports are not
written for the purpose of research
they're written for the purpose of
either clinical findings or for
administrative purposes and so there's
not as much information in there as you
could like there to be and then so let's
say you have let's say you have the
information and you're able to do
natural thing with processing on it and
get everything out from it then there's
honestly one problem I think exist in
radiology which doesn't exist in a lot
of other fields is that there might not
be one truth there's this concept of
interobserver variability they're given
three or four expert radiologists they
might all look at the image the same
image and say completely different
things about that image and none of them
are communal are actually wrong because
it's open to interpretation it's much
more of an art than a science reading
radiographs and so I think it's much
harder to say what the ground truth
actually is when trying to build these
algorithms until I'll talk about the
quantity of images we can work with so
on the Left once again we have our
radiograph on the right we have our
pretty our cute koala so most of these
studies at least for the natural
language of natural language natural
image studies we're looking at these
natural pictures we're talking on the
order of tens of thousands of thousands
to tens of millions of images which is
what we kind of need to build these
we're talking about medical imaging
we're usually talking about hundreds to
thousands or tens of thousands which is
why I said that CT study was pretty
impressive but then it was going to only
had 30,000 30,000 30,000 CTS however the
problem is actually more tired
because the classes aren't even right
when we're talking about natural images
you're usually talking about even
classes I have the same number of
pictures but I always have more pictures
of dogs and everything else but I have
enough pictures of koalas I've llamas I
can get enough of that data in most of
these cases most radiographs are just
normal people are healthy for the most
part they do not have these diseases so
10% positive is actually really high we
find usually about one to two percent
positive cases so now my 10,000
quote-unquote cases has now gone down to
ten cases so now 10 positive cases from
which to learn everything and let's talk
about the sources and this is part of
the reason why I don't have so many
images right anyone could go to the zoo
and take a picture you're not really no
no you can't we'll just walk into an
x-ray and say okay I'd like to take
x-rays or the next five people it's fine
don't worry about it I'll give you 20
bucks on the side right it's not nearly
as simple to get these images out and a
big problem with that besides which is
the medical issue is the fact that
there's just so much cost associated
with medical imaging that just does not
exist in other fields so we have a lot
less data it's a lot hard to know the
truth about it it's a lot more complex
and then just to make things harder
because why not let's talk about
artifacts so on the right this is from
the explaining and harnessing
adversarial examples paper that was
published about I think two years ago
this is a great paper which is talking
about how we train computer vision
algorithms and so on the left what we
have is a panda and the model has a
fifty seven point seven percent
confidence for it if we then add a
little bit of pixel noise to it and we
then look at it again to us or to me it
looks like a panda I haven't seen any
change in this image
however the machine learning the
computer vision algorithm now believes
with 99% confidence that this is a
Gibbon which is a monkey which is not
really the same thing as a panda and so
the problem is artifacts and radiology
are extremely common so I'm not sure for
the people looking back into this but on
the left what we see over here is I have
no mouse but pretty much on the left
we're seeing something called a
mirroring artifact and then we have a
texturing artifact and these are very
common in radiology just because of the
way the technology is built and they
happen all the time and for us there's
not really an issue we can see very
easily passed these artifacts but they
exist all the time
and it's very hard for the machine
learning algorithms to see past them I
mean some theorize that maybe the
machines are rising up a little earlier
than we predicted but who knows
I just things but and forget about pixel
noise pixel noise exists in all of these
images so we have images are more
complex we don't know what they actually
mean we have less images we have a lot
less images and we have otherwise and
there's just artifacts that exists
within them and I think there's one more
thing I want to talk about so if we look
at the automobile industry right there's
not just self-driving cars we've been
using artificial intelligence in all the
auto industry for years now right
everything from Google Maps tool anuses
to you know fraud detection for
insurance claims to monitoring the car
systems to a couple years about I think
it was a year ago right they were trying
to build better cars or design better
cars using deep learning algorithms
every aspect of the auto industry is
infused with artificial intelligence and
I think the problem is we have a tool we
have computer vision algorithms which
can identify pictures and we said what
can we apply it to and I think that's
very short-sighted because there's so
much more to radiology than just images
and I think the problem is we're not
seeing what else we can add so I went
and asked a couple of radiologists what
they actually have what they actually
need help with not just trying to guess
at it or do it myself I asked them what
they need help with and this is some of
the responses I got one they want to
flag cases that are technically poor and
need to be repeated so this is a
computer vision problem but one that
most people aren't really working on
there are a couple of companies and a
couple of groups but very few just
saying hey this is a bad study repeat
the study or patient scheduling
efficiency right on average every
percent of patients who miss
appointments cost hospitals and medical
systems about a million dollars each
every year so if we can we just reduce
the amount of patients and miss
appointments you're saving the hospital
millions of dollars prioritizing exams
containing emergent findings so this is
something also a computer vision
algorithm can work on right if
something's new or different for that
patient not just different compared to
the normal x-ray but different compared
to the patient's previous one that's
something that's really interesting and
providing better image quality with
lower dose or shorter scan time so you
don't have to sit in the MRI in that
really tiny space for 40 minutes will be
really nice
in and out within five minutes because a
big problem with these studies is also
MRIs take a long time to work with - a
long time to do and if we can get them
done in half the time that's a great
value add and I think the problem is one
of the big problems artificial
intelligence is that we're not looking
at these other issues we think we know
what like we're coming at this with this
hammer with the solution trying to find
a problem versus the other way around so
now that I've kind of depressed all of
us let's talk about the future of
artificial intelligence or radiology so
I think once again xkcd has a great
point on this right right that's so
there I think all the captures right so
that's so much of AI is just figure out
ways to offload work on to random
strangers I think it's a great point so
here's what I think the future of
radiology and artificial intelligence
and radiology and honestly all of
clinical medicine lies is in these
integrated clinical data science teams
within hospitals so you have eight you
have this set on the top right that
Stanford Hopkins do Mount Sinai I'm part
of the mono furor amount of your health
system which is a system of health 11
hospitals serving the Bronx and
Westchester in New York we have our own
Center for health dated innovations and
so I'd like to now do at the end for the
end the presentation is talk about two
different projects that are currently
going on one by US and one by MGH which
I think highlight the way we can do
radiology in artificial intelligence so
the project I'm working on is called
spinal cord compression so when patients
have cancer that cancer can spread to
other parts of the body that's term
metastatic cancer one of the places you
can commonly go is the spine whichever
then expand it presses on the spinal
cord and can cause permanent lower limb
paralysis shooting pains and loss of
bowel and bladder control so radiation
oncology department came to us and said
help we need help with this problem
because if we don't diagnose these
patients as early as possible they will
lose the ability to walk permanently so
hopefully you can see this on the right
as a normal spinal canal and so we're
looking at the side view or here are the
different here left on the vertebra and
the vertebra and on the left side over
there is a patient with spinal cord
compression and you can see there's a
very much wavy pattern that is an
unhealthy spine and so we did is we
started with about 70,000 spinal MRIs
and we took from them all the radiology
reports the clinical finding and the
clinic
we then applied this passes through a
natural language processing pipeline
using machine learning and we came out
with these spinal cord compression
cohorts now these aren't extremely
accurate these are only mostly accurate
because it's a weak learner but the nice
thing about this is we do have
radiologists on staff
so pretty much we bug them on their
nights and weekends to label our images
for us and say okay is this image have
spinal cord compression does it have
cancer is it normal
we've also picked a project in which
there is a ground truth because there
are radiological radiology radiological
findings which are pretty much
standardized across the industry we then
pass it through a CNN and I'm being a
little too vague a pound I'm gonna be a
little bit vague about what algorithms
were using because it's not really ready
for primetime just yet and we're able to
get spinal cord compression
identification this thing goes through
prospective validation that's a nice
thing about working with the hospital is
we can now run this in real time without
actually implementing anything and just
checking are we catching the cases
before the radiologists are and then
eventually our goal is to integrate this
with the radiology tech stack because
we're working really tightly with the
with the hospital they're ready for us
to implement to the second we have
validated that study and then just one
more quick study this is a deep spine
this was a paper put out by V by MGH
center for clinical data science so
their issue they were working with with
spinal stenosis
apparently spine is the new hotness in
imaging so if we look what they're
looking at is something similar but
actually a quite different etiology is
they were looking at spinal canal
stenosis so that's narrowing of the
spinal canal and how they can
automatically grade their radiological
images because they just go through so
many of these a day and their analysis
are getting backed up on these images so
what they did is they have about 7,000
lumbar MRIs they took their they took
out all the radiology reports once again
they passed it through an NLP pipeline
and they got disk level grading ie at
every level of a vertebra they're able
to pull out the Associated finding once
again they oval toe they chose a problem
for which there was a relatively
straightforward solution then
concurrently what they did was they had
their radio radiologists go and label
the images themselves and identify the
edges of this of the vertebra they then
pass that through a unit to pull out the
individual vertebral levels using the
resin x50
and those were individual vertebral
levels as well as the supervised
learning they're getting from the disk
level grading they were now able to
build a computer vision algorithm to
automatically grade
the individual discs something they're
able to do relatively simply or
relatively simply because they started
with all the information at their
fingertips and they work with the
radiologist to label the images as well
as attack a problem which they need help
with and that was solvable and I think
that's really the key and so I want to
end with a quote that's actually we're
not real no one's really sure who said
if I think it's really true is that AI
will not replace radiologists
radiologists who use a I will replace
radiologists who don't thank you
[Applause]
thank you Michael we have time for just
a couple of quick questions
very nice presentation thank you very
much full disclosure I'm a radiologist
also and I do deep learning also the
points you made on checks net and the
Stanford study were you know pretty well
known a lot of people myself
Sarab yah and as well as Luke Oakland
Raider has discussed the problems with
the chest x-ray 14 dataset from the NIH
which chest that was based on as well as
the you know the the relatively weak NLP
labeling a lot of people are going
through that you know and and redoing it
and of course the deep radiology net you
know from deep radiology is kind of a
joke as most of us know the the issue
being is that I was gonna I was going to
give you a hard time about that but you
you you wisely put in that AI will be
used by radiologists to replace
radiologists who don't use a on I think
that that's pretty common the
opportunities that exist in imaging and
healthcare are falling nicely into these
workflow solutions which you touched on
and you know segmentation and
classification algorithms tied into EHR
that promote faster workflow and in fact
some very interesting recent
publications by Peter Chang out of UCLA
I believe and also that was on brain
bleeds and I think replicated by the MGH
team and then also the pneumothorax
detection by Andrew Taylor out of UC SF
so these things are starting to come
around you know but they're binary
classification problems you know instead
of multi-class classification which is
what geoff hinton
and you know and routing you know was
talking about years ago so maybe the
take-home point is that the opportunity
is for binary classification algorithms
for one particular path
to address one particular pain point and
I think that that's one of the things
that the ACR DSi has put out in their
recent list of you know areas in AI that
need help
but multi-class classification problems
to replace the radiologists I think are
pretty well understood to be good luck
yes I would agree with that completely
right I think that we're finding now is
that when we have specific problems
which radiologists have that's where a
eyes can be really helpful and saying
okay we have one specific issue which we
try to identify one thing and we have
all the state about that and even then
it's being tempered by the idea of is a
cell with AI it's not just everything
that doesn't work we can work if we
choose specific problems for which AI is
a great solution we're gonna get great
results and I think knowing those
problems is I think the key to helping
radiology and artificial intelligence
one more quick question
pleasure having lunch with you yesterday
by the way your phrase radiologists who
use AI this is gonna become a common
theme for a lot of different professions
X who use AI are going to become better
have you been able to forecast what will
that enable them to do be more accurate
sit back more will they be less
intelligent in the future because
they're relying on computers like an a
pilot an airplane what do you think the
radiologists of the future who use AI
are going to be different from today in
terms of what's going on in their brain
so I think a big thing or a big thing we
have in the hospital is talking about
working at the top of your license
working at your most efficient level so
a big part of radiology is measuring the
area of or measuring the diameter or the
area or the volume of what's a masses
that is a waste of time is literally
drawing ruler and then measuring the
volume of something stuff like that data
right now that array I can you know I
mean get rid of so it's getting rid of
those menial tasks which they have to do
but honestly isn't really that
complicated anyone could do with this a
little knowledge can do those tasks and
I think that's really where the value
add will start and so they're really
working on only the hard cases or things
where it's not so simple what's actually
happening over here so I think in fact
they'll probably even have to be smarter
than they were before because they're
only dealing with the difficult cases
and all the easy stuff is gonna be done
weighted by the artificial intelligence
algorithms
thanks again thank you
[Applause]